hello I'm gav we're the slowmo guys
whenever we get a new camera I feel like
it's always good to do a little speed
comparison on a classic Benchmark
experiment we've done before for example
spinning some sort of media too fast
until it explodes but we haven't done
one with the TMX yet what shall we spin
until it explodes Dan only other sort of
physical media I could think of was a
VHS video yeah and you're going to spin
that on the dice and how uh I was
thinking more along the line
of one of these bad boys what is that oh
this is a laser disc I've never seen one
of those before well they were a little
bit before our time by about a decade
and weren't immensely popular in Europe
but um in a lot of ways technologically
more advanced than a VHS and even DVD in
some ways we've got this Dyson M here
we've used it before it's trusty spins
it lots and lots of RPMs and to
gradually get to that RPM we're going to
use this varak rather than just turning
on and and immediately maxing it out
which might not get what the effect
we're after is put in the center as much
as I can enjoying uh as you're talking
focusing on you through the laser disc
so oh going for an artsy one here ready
to go oh nice little Le in there thank
you personalized yeah you got that for
me I did what what did I put on it uh
you put the slowmo guys damn and what
else what else did I put on there you
also put Jed piece be let me see I was
really appreciating it whipped out the
blade later on saw that got annoyed it's
most it's
97% a really nice gift I think yeah I
think you should do that with all your
gifts from now on to anyone just hide
somewhere like a like a non- gift part
I've never seen the jur you never seen
the jur oh wow yeah speaking of the r
Jer R Jer let's go for it cranking it
up
[Music]
oh oh my
goodness oh
dear
oh okay oh my
um
no
oh off camera gav was
like you think you think this would be
all right I was like yeah yeah yeah
Marine ply it'll be fine you know this
was used to ship a ton of equipment if
if we were just laid like this it'd be
like the French execution sort of like
Guillotine but modern
day all right let's Wow Let's armor this
up shall we yeah I think we're going to
need to this ply is not going to cut it
I mean sorry this is going to cut this
ply oh look at that so cool the colors
are amazing this is slow this looks
slower I wonder if the RPM was any
different to to last time wa got one
completely in half that's insane this
that looked like that's the neatest cut
yeah looks like a
pizza oh oh it knocked its
nut bang that shattered it there's a
brief moment of peace and then it all
comes back yeah just shattered against
the
wall
oh it just like came off the
label oh wow that's different behavior
that is just huge chunks you can see
which ended up in the ceiling there yeah
they are sharp they are jaggies
lethal jaggies oh look you can see the
dust it turns to dust when it hits the
floor oh maybe we should do a wider one
then that's what happens should do some
wide yeah just do some wide because the
first part is interesting we have seen
that before but also the pure heft of it
exploding is I think we did the the CD
at like
170,000 if I remember correctly so this
isn't as fast as that but it's such a
bigger distance for the crack to travel
it looks like it's the slowest form I
wonder if you could measure the speed of
the the
crack and how much relative to the speed
of the disc is you know can measure it
all that'd be fun
220 M an
hour W that is quite a difference this
segment of the video is sponsored by
betterhelp an online therapy service
whose aim is to make therapy more
accessible and affordable especially to
those in more remote areas where it's
more difficult to find and get started
on therapy as I've mentioned in the past
I do therapy regularly to learn new
skills but mainly to process a lot of
the strange things that have happened in
my life up to this point getting started
is very easy it's all online it's all
remote you can just answer a few
questions and you get matched with a
therapist based on your answers and then
if that person's not right for you or
you don't mesh well with that one you
can keep trying new therapists until you
feel like you found the right one and
then just regularly book that one and
then you're off even if you just use it
as an introduction to therapy so if
you're struggling consider some online
therapy with better help you can click
on the link in the description or go to
betterhelp.com slowmo thanks to
betterhelp for sponsoring this video
back to the
action if this was flat down like
horizontal it would be lethal no one
would have any shins left or
jugular on the regular camera footage in
150th of a second it went from this to
that some's gone through the the second
oh yeah there's Chunk in there yeah it's
just it's just cutting we're slowly
cutting this crate in half both sides of
the disc have come unstuck look oh I
wonder if that came unstuck in the thing
or on impact and it just dislodged
itself yeah so this will really show us
less so the cracks but more the impacts
on the surrounding how many pieces you
Reon it will go into uh seven I'm going
to go nine oh you saw the colors change
just before it cracked the split second
before it cracked oh there's actually a
shock wave there's a Ripple do you see
it yeah like a like dropping a stone
into a pool these are all Breaking from
the inside still massive chunks 1 2 3 4
5 six yeah fair
enough oh it hit the oh it hit the that
must have been what deaminated it that's
that must cuz it hit so close on the
edge it must have just shifted them all
apart a yeah I think you're right
wow oh man 30 the wood had no chance all
these hanging pieces here show you just
how fast we're actually shooting I like
the little Reflections it looks like
flash Photography in a crowd yeah as you
can see from this I'm now at 17,500
frames a second uh about half height
resolution and just hope that that's
where some cracks are
[Music]
yeah wo
the colors are just immense aren't they
yeah they're really cool
ow just sharp shards bit laser to skim
my knee oh yeah you can see there's like
a small ripple at the front of that
crack got two cracks perfectly in there
look at the colors that's so
cool really is cool yeah it's say all
that about uh 4 hours of footage from
that ah done it so many times that this
is kind of coming a little bit wonky
yeah imagine vacuuming with this now it'
be
like and suddenly your floor explodes
yeah okay a slight repo and um I thought
we could kill two birds with one stone
see the destructive power on a melon and
cut our lunch up I mean judging by the
damage it's done to the wood yeah I
can't imagine the melons going to have a
great
time
oh dear that might have sent something
in yeah there's something in there
there's definitely something in there
the whole thing's moving up and down the
whole motor's smoking the whole motor is
like going up and
down those are some big old chunks they
were M straight through on the left huge
so the bit that went in was a rebound it
was a Ricochet it didn't no way oh if
this melon takes a direct hit it is a
goner I think it might just go in
[Music]
half significant bang but a significant
melon
remains come on just went it a little
bit that's the tiniest cut it just
scraped it it gave it the tiniest slit
on the front spun around it gave it a te
slit on the back yeah yeah if it was in
any other orientation it just sliced it
clean in
[Music]
half oh oh
dear oh yeah lunchtime is that the piece
that went in first is now
revealed or is that the piece that cut
it look you can see oh wow where this is
that was probably the same piece that
maybe came well this is only one of the
halfes of the laser disc cuz they're
obviously split delaminated again yeah
it's delaminated so couldn't do better
than that with a
[Music]
knife it cracked but not all the way to
the Edge by the looks of it it's just
sort of weakened maybe it's one half of
the lamination just slowly working its
way around will it eventually be the
main crack oh a different crack yeah
that's that's a new one but then this
one also cracked oh it's shattered on
the thing again that's why it's getting
all bent oh look just straight in
perfect just all the way in completely
inside it looks like it went behind the
melon looks like a magic trick that
couldn't been better aim look at that
the melon hasn't even moved this thing's
just working its way through and the
there's not enough time for the melon to
react see you later like a bullet I'll
just drop you off in the melon like a
flet flet yeah God there's Carnage right
now look at all these pieces over here
just a melon slowly falling gravity is
barely registering at this speed you're
seeing loads of flashes of color see all
this this light and all these tiny
spinning pieces so the melon wasn't
split in half by the actual yeah it was
probably 85% ran
through look at the bloody baseball oh
man that's the most lethal thing we've
spun so far it is it is I thought the
record would be pretty lethal cuz it's
just so rigid and it's much thicker than
a CD but it was so bendy and brittle it
was much more flexible wasn't it this
stayed in massive
sharp sort of penetrative chunks getting
through wood like that thick like it was
nothing yeah I wasn't actually surprised
but I was like I was worried it would go
through but when it happened I was like
it went through can you believe it
didn't mess about did it much much
heavier must be the the double
plastic yeah some of it delaminated
separately which is odd yeah well
hopefully you found that as uh
entertaining SL shocking as we did I'm
sure we'll revisit that again in the
future with a different camera like a re
re wait re re re visit I think
technically that's that's correct okay
make sure you subscribe if you love
slowmo and we'll see you in the next
video goodbye bye-bye
[Music]
wait wait